hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book eleven of his city of God
Augustine considers a question about
creation and evil if God created
everything and saw that it was good then
why do we encounter evil within the
world and this is indeed a deep and
pressing question he notes that it
constitutes a problem for many people
and that there's multiple solutions to
it not all of which he thinks are
actually correct a few of which we'll
look at at the end of this so if God
creates everything why are there things
that are wrong things that are evil this
requires us to think a bit about what do
we actually mean by evil when we use
that word or badness you can you know
Mahlum could be translated either way
there's many different ways of
understanding what's evil and at one
extreme we might conceive of what we
call moral evil so the person who sits
down and deliberately hurts another
being you know the kid who's pulling the
wings off of a fly and laughing while
he's doing so or the adult who cheats
and lies and and takes pleasure in doing
that or if you want to use a theological
context you might think of the devil and
the fallen angels you know tempting
other human beings trying to get them to
participate in their own corruption well
with that we can talk about the will the
human free will or the will of other
rational creatures as being responsible
for that introduction of evil into the
world and to some degree that gets God
off the hook there are some problems
that can come up with that later but why
did God create wills that could could
fall or turn away or do the wrong thing
but we're going to put that aside for
the moment that's that's a very
interesting question but it's not so
germane to this this other type of evil
that is traditionally distinguished
which is what we call natural evil
and natural evil has less to do with
somebody saying I want to do the wrong
thing or I'm going to do what I think is
the right thing which actually turns out
to be the wrong thing like I'm gonna
follow my sexual desire or my desire for
for drinking or my desire for revenge
and then I do something bad there's a
whole natural world that's filled with
things that we perceive as bad that we
don't like I mean just take we've got
some examples that we can look at with
agostina just think about a camping trip
right you go camping and you forget some
of your supplies so you forgot bug spray
and now you've got mosquitoes buzzing
around your head and if you're you know
if you know much about mosquitoes
firsthand you know it's not any fun they
buzz in your ears and then they they you
know bite you and they stick their
proboscis into you and suck your blood
out and then afterwards it itches and
you have to take care of it and then
here comes some more mosquitoes right
why did God make mosquitoes why not have
a universe where there's none of these
stinging things or you might get after
the mosquitoes get you then you find a
couple ticks on you and you're worried
about how am I gonna get a disease you
know maybe I'll get lines and then you
you know depending on where you are here
in Wisconsin you could get what we call
chiggers which are these things that
burrow into your flesh and it's terribly
and you're not supposed to scratch it
right that's just an example and then
think about the other things that can
happen while you're camping you know you
spend the day outside and you get
sunburned and your skin is peeling and
blistering and all this is awful you
know or you bring your food and the
raccoons steal it now you're hungry
because is growling and you're like I
wish I brought some more food all right
we should hit it up in the the trees
like they told me to do and then you
know maybe a bear comes and tears down
your tent and chases you away and we
could go on and on and on and on and on
right he is as the examples which are
good perfectly fine examples of fire
fires you know done a lot of damage just
think about all the damage
happened this year with the California
wildfires won't be the last year by the
way frost you know people lose their
fingers their toes their noses sometimes
they they completely die frost comes
along and kills your beautiful flowers
that you put out or when you put your
seedlings out that you've planted or
you've you know just planted that the
seeds in the field and you've got some
good crops going along comes the frost
and kills them all all right and it even
makes the things look disgusting
afterwards the frost burn wild beasts I
mentioned bears chasing you if you get
caught by a bear
you're probably going to have a lot of
trouble you know they've got advice for
you but there's nothing that says the
advice is actually gonna work and
there's all sorts of other kinds of wild
beasts even our own tame beasts there
was a guy who died from his dog licking
him and giving him a disease otherwise
seemingly fairly healthy man so there's
all these sorts of things then we can
add in natural disasters we can add in
you know various weather things that
don't kill us but inconvenience us you
know you're walking to school and you've
got your your paper printed out and here
comes a downpour and now your paper is
completely soaked because you didn't put
it in a briefcase or something like that
and we can go on and on and on right so
Augustine says yeah these these are
experienced as evil why because they
injure or destroy our frail flesh and we
could go further and say they not only
destroy and injure or inconvenience our
frail flesh they also mess around with
all the other stuff that we like all of
our tools like books clothing you know
recording devices they they screw all
these things up so Augustine isn't
saying that the universe doesn't contain
all these sorts of processes things that
vex us
time's kill us make us hurt but he says
they're good in themselves
they're bad for us in a certain way but
they are good in themselves and he tells
us a number of different ways in which
this occurs and he says this is what we
could look at this is what we could
consider he says we could consider how
admirable these things are in their own
places how excellent in their own nature
so let's pause on that and just take a
few examples think about fire fire is
incredible without it the human race
could not have advanced and it's
beautiful to watch it's also you know
kind of scary if you're caught in a fire
and it burns the hell out of you if you
if you're not careful but fire is pretty
impressive isn't it wild beasts are
pretty cool too that's why people like
watching nature shows or going to zoos
there's something incredibly impressive
about watching a bear or a giraffe or a
wolf or even I don't know what you're
into but I like watching spiders I think
they're they're fascinating creatures so
in themselves there's something
admirable about admirable about them he
says how beautifully adjusted to the
rest of creation and how much grace they
contribute to the universe by their own
contributions as to a common well let's
take the mosquito again right we could
say let's kill all those all those damn
mosquitoes well if we do that there's a
lot of other animals that are gonna
suffer that live on those mosquitoes and
there is a point to them within this
great chain that we call the ecosystem
and an Augustine has a conception of
that there he doesn't think that the
whole purpose of mosquitoes being put on
earth is just to suck blood out of us
and make us angry and crazy and upset
and you know raised welts on us there's
there's other points to it they're part
of a Commonwealth a framework that the
divine established so they are good in
themselves in a certain way it's when
things go go wrong with them he said
they are serviceable even to ourselves
if we use them with a knowledge of their
fit adaptation so it's not just that
they're good and themselves are good
within their their microcosm or
macrocosm it's also they can be good for
us now there's not a hell of a lot we
can do with mosquitoes but think about
all the other things that we have
adapted animals plants the the
environment itself to do to to suit us
there's so many incredible uses that we
get out of things many of them just for
luxuries but some of them for
life-saving or life enhancing purposes
so what does it take for that we have to
have knowledge and we have to use them
rightly an Augustine points out even the
things that we normally consider to be
good things we can misuse them and they
can screw us up that doesn't mean that
they become bad things and he gives you
examples food drink the light of the Sun
right food you need to eat it can you
make yourself fat can you make yourself
sick can you do all sorts of other
things to yourself with food yes
same thing with drink even the light of
the Sun which we need in order to
continue life either that or you got to
go under a sunlamp or take some vitamin
D what happens if you take too much of
it
well you can get skin cancer you can get
sunburn you can have all sorts of other
things happen to you so it's it's not as
if there's anything wrong with nature
and the natural world and natural things
as such it's very context dependent and
Augustine is pointing out we have some
control over a good portion of that
context don't we so he goes on and he
says that you know we ought to carefully
investigate the use of all of these
things so that we can make the best use
of them he gives the example of medicine
a lot of medicines are actually poisons
that we adapt in a certain respect and
provide at the right time in the right
measure and then they work out good for
us so he says that you know if we think
about the creation as such it
in fact created good and here's where he
turns to talking about this priority of
goodness over evil or another way we can
say this the goodness of creation is
primary we can find some what we call
natural evil but it's not even truly
evil in the same sense that moral evil
is and here's where he thinks that a few
other at his time major representatives
of theological adaptation of philosophy
and several other ways of doing
metaphysics within a theological context
are fundamentally mistaken he targets
the Manicheans who are a very popular
group at his time a church that he
actually belonged to and he says that
some people suppose that an evil nature
has been generated and propagated by a
kind of opposing principle proper to it
so that evil would in fact have genuine
existence it would not simply be a lack
or absence or privation of the good but
rather its own sort of force personified
he says these people refuse to admit
that the cause of the creation was this
that the good God produced a good
creation they think instead that he is
already at war so to speak or engaging
in a bit of you know guerrilla warfare
with this this evil creation that's
already been put and then you've got
these two forces in opposition and
Augustine says that doesn't really work
for the creative world the other person
that he talks about is Origen who is a
Christian theologian and Origen went to
some extremes you could say in some of
the positions that he adopted and
promulgated and Origen had this view
that as Augustine is setting it out that
we're sort of souls imprisoned within
this earthly creation so he says these
people say that souls are created by God
but they sinned by abandoning guy
and in proportion of the various sins
they merited various degrees of
debasement from heaven to earth and
diverse bodies as prison houses and so
this world is itself a prison house and
he says well that doesn't really work
and here's one argument why it seems
like if that's the case the worse you
are the more corporeal you ought to be
the more base you ought to be and we
don't even see that with human beings
but I mean think about the case of the
devil and the fallen angels they then
shouldn't have you know ethereal bodies
or existences they should be as gross
and corporeal as possible but that
doesn't really make sense and and he
thinks that these are mistaken
conceptions of creation that would say
that creation is naturally evil or at
least the world that we have is
naturally evil and then God somehow
makes some good out of it intrudes some
good Augustine's is saying no everything
is good there is also moral evil caused
by wills there is what we perceive as
natural evil which is badness but it's
not badness in itself it's just poorly
adapted goodness of some sort or an
absence of the goodness that ought to be
there so this is a very important
discussion in in book 11 it connects up
with many other discussions along the
same lines that Augustine has and it
represents as I pointed out an attempt
to bring a metaphysical principle and
perspective within a larger Christian
theological framework
you